hello i am stephen purser a district  councillor for the teen valley  firstly i would like to offer my deepest  condolences  to all those who have lost relatives  friends and loved ones in these awful  pandemic months  hopefully the future looks brighter and  the world is slowly getting to grips  with controlling the virus  at this time i would like to give my  heartfelt thanks  to all those who have helped out in any  way  during these troubled times the  community and individual responses  however small or large have enabled us  to come through  these truly awful times many thanks  again  to everyone for their help may the  future be brighter  for us all